يعتبر هذا العمل من التخويف العسكري الصيني
بالقرب من تايوان غير
مسبوق من حيث حجمه
وتعقيده ، يقول المحللون إنه
لم يكن
مجرد نوع واحد من الطائرات التي تحلق ، بل
كان نوعين من الطائرات المقاتلة جنبًا إلى جنب مع
القاذفات النووية
المضادة للغواصات وطائرات الإنذار المبكر.
سويًا حتى أثناء الطيران
إلى
جنوب جزيرة تايوان ، يقول المحللون
إن هذه المهمات ربما تم
التخطيط لها قبل أسابيع عديدة ولكن تم
تجميعها وتجميعها
في اللحظة الأخيرة على الأرجح
ردًا على البيان المشترك لمجموعة السبع الذي
يوبخ الصين من قبل قادة
أغنى دول العالم بشأن قضايا
تشمل قمع
الحركة المؤيدة للديمقراطية في هونغ كونغ ،
واتهامات الإبادة الجماعية ضد مسلمي
الأويغور في شينجيانغ
وأعمال التخويف العسكري المستمرة
هنا في تايوان ،
وهي جزيرة ادعت بكين أنها
أراضيها السيادية لأكثر من 70
عامًا
حتى  على الرغم من أن هذه الجزيرة كانت
تحكم نفسها طوال ذلك الوقت ، إلا
أنها في الواقع  الديمقراطية الوحيدة
الناطقة بالصينية في العالم ولكن
معظم الدول لا تعترف بهذه
الحكومة رسميًا لأن بكين
التي تتمتع بالكثير من القوة النارية الاقتصادية والعسكرية
تصر على سياسة الصين الواحدة التي
يوقعها الرئيس الحالي عندما
لا تعترف بأن المتحدث باسمها
كولا قد أصدر بيانًا بشأن  تويتر
يقول إن
الطائرات الحربية الصينية قامت بـ 28 عملية توغل غير ضرورية
في مضيق تايوان اليوم
مما أضاف إلى انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون في الصين تهدئة
لا تايوان ولا الأرض هي
عدوك ،
فقد كانت هناك أحداث في الأسبوع
ونصف الماضي أو نحو ذلك يمكن اعتبارها
سلائف
لهذا لا  فقط بيان مجموعة السبع ولكن أيضًا
في السادس من يونيو
عندما هبط ثلاثة أعضاء من مجلس الشيوخ الأمريكي هنا في
تايبيه على
متن طائرة نقل عملاقة من طراز C-17 لحضور جلسة تصوير مدتها ثلاث ساعات
مع الرئيس سيان ون في اجتماع قصير
معها والإعلان عن تبرع الولايات المتحدة بـ
kobit 19  لقاحات لتايوان
يقول المحللون إنه يمكن أن يُنظر إليها أيضًا على
أنها تحدٍ مذل لمزاعم بكين
بالسيادة على هذه الجزيرة.
ردود الفعل تأتي من
بكين إذا كانوا يعتقدون أن الولايات المتحدة
وتايوان يقتربان من تحالف عسكري
صرح به المشرعون الأمريكيون ، وقالت بكين
منذ فترة طويلة إنها لن
تستبعد استخدام القوة
لمنع تايوان من الانفصال
عن البر الرئيسي.  ريبلي سي إن
تايبيه